she sent it to me obviously the finale
of the reel and you being left out and
we were like
that stepped up this is wrong and
jeannie's like what what do we do what
do we do amanda seals is finally getting
some closure after being snubbed from
the reels finale episode i am not
featured in
this thumbnail and i am not featured in
the
uh farewell episode apparently
i'll have some things to say about that
it's been a little over a week since the
real rap for good fans flooding social
media and that time to stand up for
amanda who co-hosted the show in 2020
from being excluded from the farewell
celebration at the end of the day if
you're going to do a retrospective of
the show over the years it's been on and
the hosts that have been on it it don't
matter what i say
you were hosting the show
i mean they kind of proved you right you
know what i mean
if you're saying that this show wasn't
good for my spirit because of x y and z
and then they purposely and
intentionally leave you out just like
which i have confirmed was the case and
now amanda is hearing from her former
co-host talking it out in a girl chat on
instagram live with adrian houghton and
jeannie mai jenkins who set the record
straight we were not aware of this and
this is obviously not okay
and i said call amanda right now like
let's facetime her right now like let's
have the conversation with her
and
that's where it begins like you can't
let somebody feel whack and not reach
out that's just who
who we are and who people should be in
general
yeah number one first is friends first
first
always first part of that is like i
thought about your feelings i was like
oh man like that doesn't feel good to be
left out of anything and and number two
i wouldn't want you to think that this
was something knowingly done on our
behalf it seems like the conversation
was much needed and healing for amanda
it's like how do you counter that
without just being quiet to yourself
like damn that's whack it's like you
have to be loud i want to shout out just
all the people who have like made it
their business to be like that was
[ __ ] up a man that was dope on the
show that shouldn't happen because you
know like the negativity can be so much
louder
[Applause]
the 40-year-old comedian left the show
after just six months as a co-host me
leaving the reel and me verbalizing the
reasons why i left the reel which i
verbalized as because one it wasn't
feeding my soul because it was being
misrepresented at the time amanda made
it clear her decision had nothing to do
with her co-host jeannie adrian plus
lonnie love and tamara mowry
shout out to jeannie shout out to tams
shout out to lonnie lonz and shout out
to adrian but y'all to understand this
grown me grown women do grown women
business that's what y'all don't
understand and what i do with my
business ain't got nothing to do with
them sisters before her early departure
from the real amanda was a welcomed
addition to the panel when she first
joined the ladies adrian praised
amanda's unique perspective to e.t i've
actually known amanda the longest out of
anyone on the panel i've always loved
who she is i've loved how opinionated
she is and that's what we really what we
love on the show is having women that
have strong opinions and bring a
different perspective
[Music]
you